sentez toujours on a appris que l'acteur
français guillaume depardieu a été
amputé de sa jambe droite
vendredi dernier le fils de gérard
depardieu blessé dans un accident de
moto et qui avait subi de nombreuses
interventions affirme avoir contracté
une infection à l'hôpital son cas est
sans doute très particulier mais il
illustre aussi la difficulté à lutter
contre ce qu'on appelle les maladies
nosocomiales
la thalie ça fait namadi terroir à la
double vente elle était insupportable
depuis sept ans à tel point que
guillaume depardieu a renoncé à se
battre et à décider l'amputation de sa
jambe droite
la douleur la tâche énorme la fatigue
enfin tous les gens qui qui subit ce
genre de choses provost le montrer
l'acteur français a été opéré la semaine
dernière dans un hôpital parisien
conséquences dramatiques d'un accident
de moto survenu en 1996 17 interventions
chirurgicales de nombreux traitements un
an d'hospitalisation n'ont pu venir à
bout d'une infection à staphylocoque
doré qui s'est niché dans l'os
l'amputation reste la solution de
dernier recours
5 à 10% des fractures ouvertes les plus
graves se termine ainsi le laisser comme
cela
dc n'importe qui guillaume depardieu
quelqu'un d'autre avec une infection
chronique n'est pas non plus exemple de
danger donc je crois qu'à un moment il
faut raisonner calmement tranquillement
c'est une décision collégiale en groupe
avec l'intéressé avec des psychologues
ou des six mois dans [ __ ] et et
l'amputation elle même est un acte en
soit parfaitement bien codifiée et fort
que dangereux le drame de cet acteur de
32 ans a ému les français devant
l'ampleur des marques de sympathie il
envisage de créer une association de
lutte contre les infections contractées
à l'hôpital